Today we are going to look at three cantos.
They are connected in a number of interesting ways.
Cantos nine,
10,
and 11.
Um,
they describe the,
they focus on,
uh,
the pilgrims and the guide Virgil being,
approaching the city of this.
So we are moving there,
they're moving and we with them away from the area of incontinence,
which is the section of a of him fender.
We read through from Canto five to Canto eight.
They're approaching it with the,
the gates of the city of this,
uh,
in Canto nine.
And the pilgrim experiences a serious impediment.
And I'm pass,
we would call it,
he cannot go any further.
The guidance of Virgil fails him and we're going to examine why it fails him.
And what is the problem that the pilgrim that we'll have to solve once he is in
Canto and within the city of this,
the first sinners he meets,
uh,
the so called heretics Harris JAKKS among whom?
Chief among whom is really Epicurus.
So they're the epicureans and in many ways you understand or that link between
the city and this philosophers.
Uh,
let me just add one thing.
So you have it.
The,
the,
the ideas a bit clear.
Dante acknowledges in this philosophical texts that he writes called a banquet,
three schools of philosophy.
Uh,
the so called academics or a strategic Ian's then the stoics and third the
epicureans.
Now he handles,
he just examines a who does epicureans are and for him,
their peers,
those who are guilty of some form of pride if you wish,
intellectual pride.
Since Harris is a question of intellect and nor have,
we'll we'll talk about that.
Uh,
they deny the immortality of the soul.
And in fact,
it's a really a problem to,
uh,
to figure out why should Dante think of the MS centers at all in,
in antiquity.
They were viewed as one more school of opinion,
philosophical opinion.
My mind that's not convinced me.
My reason.
That's not find it convincing.
Uh,
the belief in the mortality of the,
so what should I be punished?
It's an intellectual since,
since the logic of Dante's old idea of sinfulness is that are the will has to be
involved,
that will is at the center of the habit of two for the habit to sin.
Um,
well we'll talk about this.
And then in canto 11,
there really is no great action.
Dante goes on explaining the,
so topography of,
of evil goes on explaining the arrangement of sins.
What is the,
what is the principle is a principle of construction of fat and they're now he
turns to Arris,
toto,
we'll turn to Aristotle's ethics first of all,
as the plan,
as the model to array for the arrangement of sense.
And then also we shall see in a very interesting way he will turn to,
he would allude to his physics.
So you see,
he goes on talking about from the,
the uh,
a personal problem at which we have to understand in Canton,
I the crisis of then the questions of the intellect and its relationship to the
world at that in [inaudible] 11,
this idea of what are the dispositions to sinfulness and we shall see and the
turn to Adis Toto.
Uh,
so let me go back to now looking at exactly the crisis of Canto and can tonight,
uh,
Dante is processing progressing in this journey.
He reaches the gate of this and now,
and this is around lines 40 foreign three furious.
That's so cold.
Three airiness of Greek mythology.
Our lacto they see for me and Maghera on the Jira,
uh,
they appear and they stopped him.
You cannot get a go into the city.
A city described very much as a medieval city.
Um,
the,
in fact it's a kind of swarm for reasons that we have nothing to do with really
ecology.
But the idea,
the medieval cities were built me a,
obviously it was,
the land was always more malleable and there was water.
It clearly in the,
in uh,
uh,
that's not the,
the,
the reason for Dante,
but division for the,
uh,
certain ways of understanding medieval medieval cities.
The three fewer worries,
uh,
electro to see for them.
Miguel will stop and uh,
and they call on the dozer who doesn't come,
but the someone Medusa,
that's where they say,
let Medusa calm.
They threatened the pilgrim with the site of the Medusa.
Let me do to calm.
This is,
she's in here.
I repeat.
This is if you had to translate it into,
into,
let's say from English into Italian,
you would use the subjunctive.
May she come?
I wish she came.
We wish she came.
Let her come,
and we will turn him to stone.
That's the threat.
A threat of Petrofac Haitian because according to the myth,
and if you don't know all of it,
for instance,
you may have seen a movie about the middle.
So if you look at the,
if you gaze at the,
the,
the phase of the Medusa,
uh,
one who gazes at the head of [inaudible] was a great a virgin or beauty,
a vessel in the temple of Neptune according to the myth of was violated by
Neptune.
And Minerva takes revenge on her by,
uh,
metamorphosing hundred,
this ugly,
repulsive figure with a hair turned into snakes.
And yet she has this power,
this magic power of turning old your lookers into stone.
So that's the threat.
Let me do a calm and we will turn him to stone.
They all cried looking down.
We avenged ill,
the assault of Theseus Theseus who also violated the boundaries of hell.
A two free,
uh,
the every tools and other little story that there were a thesis who was
successful in the liberation of very tools,
uh,
the,
this,
the drama involving the pilgrim directory.
This is,
this is a,
uh,
a manners on him.
Turns their back.
This is virtual intervenes and keep that nice shot.
Four,
should the Gorgon Medusa show herself and I'll see her.
They would be no returning above.
Now that's a term.
Listen to this.
My master said this and himself turned me around and not trusting to my hands,
covered my face with this home.
Also
report in corrupts the narrative and talks to us as a poet.
This is the first so called address to the reader.
I will talk about this little little technical detail.
This will say this is no longer part of the action.
Now it's no longer the pilgrim at the story of the pilgrim,
but the poet who is sitting in his study and who says you,
who are of good understanding the talent says you have healthy intellects.
We will have a good understanding.
Note,
the teaching that is hidden under the veil of the strange lines,
the poet,
uh,
assuming authority terms to us readers.
And in a sense,
he needs to be nourished so that he's authority can be constituted.
And he,
he warns us,
he admonishes us to engage in what a clear appears is that as an our lego recall
or allegorical operation,
we have to read.
And the language is the language of allegory.
We have to know how to read underneath the,
the veil,
that language.
There's something hidden underneath this.
Uh,
what is the allegory about,
um,
so the,
the,
uh,
let me just give you more about the story of the myth of [inaudible].
So you will see the relevance may be of that myth and the,
the,
uh,
what I left out of the myth of two,
four,
two,
this,
uh,
this scene now,
as you know,
the Medusa will be conquered,
will be defeated,
right?
Uh,
she will be defeated by the poet,
by Perseus who on,
it's the origin of Pegasus,
the,
the whole list of poetry.
A Pegasus,
I'm sorry,
Perseus who using the shield of Minerva,
they shield that Minerva had given him.
And by looking not at Medusa Directorate that have faced that accurately,
but I did reflected image in this shield in the mirror of the shield of be
nervous managers to see how and we'll kill it.
We'll slay the Medusa.
Okay.
Uh,
uh,
in the story within the Avidia narrative,
this is clearly a meant to evoke for us the need for a kind of,
not a direct vision,
but a mediated vision,
uh,
this to say through the mediation of poetry for us through the mediation of a,
come back to the scene in a moment,
but through the mediation of the shield can pursues a really take flight kill
and then take fight on the back of a Pegasus.
For us,
the shield of Minerva is the text because at this point is he the,
there is a sort of direct,
uh,
con let's say divergence between what the pilgrim is enjoying to do.
Virtual says to him,
don't look shut.
Your eyes end up trusting the pilgrim,
either his quickness.
Yeah,
it must've been all by,
by this situation.
He doesn't understand.
He covers,
he Virgil covers,
uh,
the pilgrim,
his own eyes.
It turn the poet addresses us and tells us to open our eyes.
You open our eyes and look,
you can because you have the shield of nerve or you have,
you have this texture mediation that will allow you to escape the direct threat
and glance of Medusa.
Uh,
so we do know that the story,
uh,
mercury,
who is the messenger,
um,
if they're clearly the figure of the interpreter,
uh,
that's what the Messenger means or are they the better of the,
of,
of messages,
the better of words he comes and,
uh,
managers to,
make a breach within the wall of the city and the pilgrim and the guide can
continue the descent.
This is really the story.
So,
uh,
what is happening?
What is,
uh,
what,
how do I have to,
can,
can we explain what is this allegory?
Let me say a few things you and understand the whole technique of our legos.
Whenever you read the divine comedy,
probably much more than I would ever do.
Others.
Other scholars will tell you that the divine comedy is a vision,
which it is.
And that is our allegorical,
which at times it is a,
and the allegory supposed to explain everything that the pilgrim finds himself
lost in the woods.
That not the woods to me it's a word,
but they say it's a state of sin in a way.
Uh,
and there he meets a three beasts that stand for our pride and wrath and
whatnot,
three beasts and they may stand for other things.
The significance of that initial landscape as you may recall when we talked
about about that scene is not all that clear.
And that's part the problem.
That's what I call the land of unlikeness within which the pilgrim who will find
himself the inability to join together signs and there significations the,
the awareness that there are no signs which are so self transparent as to be
understood or decor divide in a particular way.
So what is this idea of allegory?
Dante here is clearly asking,
telling us that it is an allegory at work.
You readers have good understanding of healthy minds are look,
uh,
open your eyes and look underneath the,
the veil of the strange verse for,
so what's the,
why are they so strange?
It's so strange.
What is the story?
What's going on here?
What is allegory?
First of all,
I'll go to this,
you know,
that word means,
uh,
to speak.
Otherwise it's a figure that is related but not quite to enigmas.
Uh,
within the,
the manuals,
the primers of rhetorical primers from medieval in classical times and
[inaudible] irony,
you know,
say one thing and you mean another,
uh,
but to say,
this is to say very little because Dante has been very thoughtful,
has been think probing this issue very deeply and in,
in,
in a couple of places of his works and the letter took ground that he writes
about,
which I will talk later.
It's a letter that he sends as an introduction to the first 10 cantors of
paradise can grant the being the load of Verona were done.
The had lived for awhile and also in the banquet,
this philosophical texts where he explores the idea of,
uh,
of what,
how it meaning can be arrived at how I have a statement,
how can I go on,
I'm drawing a particular significance or more than one significance or part of,
of estate.
And he distinguishes two types of allegory.
Let me show you are two types of allegory and there is a so called Aligote of
poets and delegative theologians.
How the sea distinguished them.
How would he ask us to distinguish between them?
The [inaudible] of poets is an allegory where the literal English,
the literal sense is a fable is a fiction to say that's the example he gives or
futures,
but the power of his language moved stones.
That's an allegory of poets.
It really means that the power of the voice of the poet managers maybe to edify
cities.
No.
Yeah.
Whether we need poetic mates for the edification of us of a city.
No,
that's,
that's understandable.
Or to say all fuse that by the power of his words came lions.
It's so it's to say that a Fubu shows this,
we may have,
insiders can partly be tamed by the music,
the song that poetry.
So that's the allegory of boards.
The literal sense is a fiction to say that it's an allegory of theologian is
completely different.
And the example of Dante gifts is pagan sends us to exodus.
The Biblical story of exodus.
You or no?
I take what the biblical,
so once again,
move his help,
uh,
the,
the biblical story of as the story where the Jews abandon leave the,
this,
the bondage,
the slavery of Egypt go through the desert and reach the promised land.
He says this is happening historically true.
This is not a fixture of this is the Red Sea did open up and the juice could,
could pass through the Red Sea,
uh,
could cross the Red Sea that this is history and in the allegory was
theologians.
The literal level must be historical.
It must be any event.
Okay,
so this is the distinction.
Of course,
the question is what kind of allegory is he using here?
Uh,
but we'll come to that in a moment.
But keep her in mind.
This is a,
I hope it's more than than,
uh,
over Carol surgical archeological interests.
The,
the,
within the allegory of theologians,
they're distinguished four levels of extra Jesus because Jesus being a word,
meaning of interpretation of four levels,
the literal,
the moral,
the center level is telling you what to do.
Teaching you,
it's an,
has an ethics involved or you read and there is an ethics when you're reading,
we have more or less a text is trying to direct your will or tell you what,
what you should be doing.
A topological telling what topological meaning,
what does it mean in terms of,
of your whole life,
not just the inaction in a particular case.
And then the so called anagogy or eschatological.
So that the story of the Jews Cross in the wilderness and going to to the
Jerusalem means,
uh,
having a kind of a spiritual conversion.
Moral conversion means that Ah,
this is the really the way life or to go and you go from sin to glory or,
or the piece of the city or,
and then analogical and this is the story of this whole,
uh,
it prefigures what the soul or to do in the case of the allegory of poets,
you'll have two levels.
The literal and the moral.
They are a lot of difficulties with this way of distinguishing between the two
types of allegory because both allegory of theologians and allegory of poet,
even if the allegory of theologians refers to events are still words that we are
reading.
So there's a way in which Dante seems to Ah,
one point dodge the whole thing of how can you really distinguish between the
two modes that to rhetorical modes independently,
one from the other.
And actually he goes on saying really the differences in how you take the
literal sense in the kind of act of faith that you may have,
that the literature says that the Bible is the word of God.
Then you are reading a theologically.
But if you decide,
and one might say that the Bible really a collection of extraordinary pointing
stories,
then you then you are reading according to the allegory of poets,
how is Dante circumventing this whole issue?
He said,
circumventing the whole issue by saying,
my story may well be taken as a story of allegory of poets,
but it's also an allegory of theologians.
Because the literal sense is I,
this is the historical sense is in me.
I am the historical cipher moving through these experiences and therefore it is
my life that there will give a particular sense,
a particular tooth value to whatever poetic fable I may be related.
We only have taken care of one little problem here.
All the very external to the story,
the allegory of poets.
Or I'll go to the theologians.
It's time to decide that this is what,
but what is going on here?
But how are we to understand this?
A threat to petrify fication and you cannot really understand that.
Uh,
but I'm here to tell you they're going to really understand it on your own.
So you have to trust my words.
The fact is that Dante had written in his youth and number of poems for a so
called lady stone and Italian.
It's not as bad as that stone could be a good word.
It was just uh,
uh,
don't know Petra,
Petra meaning stone and the passion it was,
it's,
it's an description of a,
a love.
There was unrequited,
but a passion for this woman was such that he felt that his intellect would be
petrified that he could be.
In other words,
he was unable to go anywhere.
It's a statement of despair if you wish,
you know,
whenever you have the sense of a death that is going to take over and,
and,
and you are going to be paralyzed in,
uh,
in your will than this is a Petrofac station.
This is what I think is happening here.
Dante is engaged in a retrospection to an experience of his past and their
experience with past is now ahead of him,
threatening him.
Once again,
he has to cleanse themselves to move beyond that.
But to explain better this idea of the closing the eyes as it's why Medusa
though he talks of Medusa there and this lady patron is a kind of a loser.
Let me give you read the little scene from that I think really explains what's
going on and prepares us to,
uh,
move.
Okay.
To move forward to the next cancer canter 10.
It's a little scene from the confessions of Augustan as you know,
a book that,
uh,
Dante knew very well.
Um,
Dante even goes on,
uh,
quoting it,
a very strategic places.
So there is not an issue of,
um,
bringing it in gratuitously to explain,
explain the scene.
Actually a direct,
uh,
it could be viewed,
forgive the,
the,
uh,
the reversal could,
this could be viewed as a gloss on what Dante,
we'll go riding.
They confession is written with,
uh,
it's an intellectual,
auto biography.
The story of a young man who will go on,
uh,
being fascinated by various schools of philosophy.
He said,
Manny Keon and then it will turn into,
into a new play.
Tunis,
uh,
goes on,
is,
is very flattered by a skeptical,
a rhetorical way.
He's a professor of rhetoric,
rhetorical way of dealing with,
uh,
with,
with the values and the world around him.
And then,
uh,
in book nine,
he'll go on telling the story in the garden of Midland,
the famous story under the fig tree,
uh,
very emblematic.
We could talk about these things,
but why the fig tree Melanne,
uh,
leads many scholars to own wondering where are they a fig trees in Moran?
Isn't it?
The climate too cold?
You need really the southern climbs for that kind of thing for getting that the
fig tree is always in the Bible,
appears as the tree under which the profits go and rest in the mistaken belief
that everything is over and that somehow the time for complacency may come
there,
are denouncing it.
Of course,
this is all done in the mode of it.
Then we'll see Asia and that's exactly where,
where,
where Augustine puts himself,
I'm under the fig tree and there he go,
goes on,
explore,
uh,
experiencing a particular drama but the reading of Saint Paul,
et Cetera,
throughout this text.
So this is about your play tourist,
uh,
and uh,
and,
and Manicheans,
uh,
as you know,
Augustan as you probably know,
Augustine goes on refracting about his love of shows.
The biggest one of them at the beginning of book three is his love of theater
and his critique of the theater.
Now why do I go to the theater and how to explain the fact that there may be
some,
uh,
a well meaning young men who sees the mail,
didn't induce stress and jumps on the scene to free her and goes on talking
about how can I be a spectator?
What does it mean to be a SPEC spectator expectation?
How does it,
what does it mean to be involved?
And then there is another little seen,
a friend of his I leap use,
um,
a leap use with uh,
uh,
a Greek intellectual in there in the best sense of the word,
a man who believes in the in self mastery and intellectual self mastery and men
who are young men who uh,
witnesses,
uh,
Augustine's hone,
um,
experiences.
You know,
in narratives you always have sandshore accompanying donkey hotel.
There is always the other,
uh,
the more or less skeptical who gives authenticity and who exactly will go on
making claims for the truth value of what the narrator,
the protagonist will go on to experience him.
His name is Ali [inaudible].
I leap,
you will eventually rejoin.
He's in Carthage.
The grew up together.
Augusta.
Then he grew up together or gas and goes to Rome.
I leap you to rejoin.
I'm in Rome and they go on from there.
Eventually we go to Milan.
When in Rome I leap use does what normal is.
We would go do the first thing he wants to do is to go and watch the games
played as a Co.
I'm fatigued.
I thought they call a seal and the Games are horrifying games for gas.
He says,
how can an intellectual such as you want to go to the games were actually human
beings are being thrown for the delight of the crowds are being thrown to two
beasts to Ryan's a leap years.
Uh,
uh,
of course he tries to justify himself,
but I really want to go.
But you know,
exactly because he'll say,
but I read that you,
because they read you the passage.
I would go.
But because of many intellectual,
I promise that at the crucial moments when the sign is given for the animal to
devour a,
the human being lying there,
I will not watch.
I work,
not going to turn my eyes away and I will shut my eyes.
Let's see what happens.
This is from book six,
Chapter Eight.
It's a great little story that by the way,
eh,
Eh,
a scholar of romance philology who used to teach here many years ago by the name
of Eddie Karbach and great Dante scholar and he wrote this book called Mimesis.
He reflects on the scene,
not connecting it with Dante,
but it doesn't matter.
I read it first in his book,
uh,
and says,
this is really,
it's a little scene that marks the end of Hellenic rationalism.
Let's read this.
And it's interesting just because of that.
Then we'll see how I could apply it to dance.
I think it's,
uh,
it's very clear he had gone to Rome to study law.
This is a,
our leafs and there he was carried away way incredibly with,
uh,
an incredible eagerness after the shows of gladiators,
okay.
For being utterly aversed when the testings are spectacles.
He was one day by chance,
by diverse of his acquaintances and fellow students coming from dinner.
And they with a familial violence,
hailed him FIM and really refusing.
You're resisting into the amphitheater during this cold war and deadly shows.
He does protesting though.
You Hail my body to that place.
This is Olivia's and they are set me,
can you force me also to turn my mind on my,
all my eyes to those shows.
I shall then be absent while present.
And so shell overcome both you and them,
they hearing this lady mourner.
Nevertheless,
these iris per chance to try that very thing,
whether he could do as he said,
when they were calm his data and had taken the places as they could,
the whole place kindled without savage pastime.
But he,
Olivia's closing the passage of his eyes for Bait,
his mind to range a broad set of such evil and what he had stopped his ears also
for in the fight when one fair,
a mighty cry of the whole people striking him strongly over combat curiosity and
this if prepared to despise and be superior to it whatsoever.
It were even when scene,
he opened his eyes and was stricken with a deeper wound in his soul than the
other,
uh,
whom he desired to be hold was in his body and he failed miserably.
Then he,
upon whose fall that might've noise was raised,
which entered through his ears and unlocked his eyes to make way for the
striking and breathing down of a soul,
bold,
rather resolute.
And the weaker in that had presumed on itself,
which ought to have relied on the four so soon.
The whole confession is addressed to God.
So it's a confession witness in to God.
So you,
in case you're confused about the references,
um,
uh,
for so soon as he saw that blood,
he there with drunk down savage anise,
not turned away but fix this AI drinking in frenzy unawares and was delighted
with that guilty fight and intoxicated with bloody pastime.
No.
Was he now the men he came but one of the throng,
he came until,
yeah,
a true or social too.
There's that brought him there.
What,
why say more?
He beheld shattered,
kindled,
carry dense with with him the madness,
which should go him to return neuro only with them who first drew him data but
also before them.
Yeah.
And to joy in others.
Yet that's the start with the most strong,
the Most merciful hand pluck him and taught him to have confidence nor in
himself,
but in the,
but this was after and that's really the story.
What is the meaning of the story in the confessions?
I think Augustine is very clear,
the failure of the mind to muster it's home.
Well it's about the crisis.
It's about the weakness of the will to begin with.
But it's also the pride that believe that one can rise above the,
let's say,
the,
the contingency sort of temptations and be in control of one's health.
And yet it's a story of a temptation,
uh,
which he,
I leap use cannot quite resist.
I think that this is exactly what's happening in Canto nine.
Dante's traumatizing,
not only the failure of the intellect,
he's already been talking about the early part of the cancer,
the failure of Virgil to guide him.
He's discussing now the failure of his will,
at least seen in as an event of the past.
But clearly it was seen as something that can happen to him again.
The passage to the city can take place after this,
uh,
this scene.
And,
and uh,
now he enters into,
into the,
uh,
city of this and against the walls of the city.
He finds the epicureans,
uh,
again,
those who all do not believe in the immortality of the soul.
Let me just read the encanto 10.
Some passers by the way,
each Canto 10 of the divine comedy,
there really are Oh Candace,
intimately related,
which with each other.
So if you were looking for a paper you want to connect,
Canto tenor of in can throw 10 of Purgatorio Canto tenor of paradise,
I would encourage you to do so.
So let me just read a few lines are Dante asks who these are salsa and the
answer he gets this line 12,
all will be shuttin when the return from Jehosaphat's,
which is the valet,
Eh,
uh,
um,
in Jerusalem down in the valley into of Jerusalem,
where according to,
uh,
the,
the law,
uh,
the resurrection of,
the,
the resurrection of the dead will take place.
That's why they,
they would be meeting.
It's interesting then that there is this contrast in the cantor between the so
called epicureans who do not believe in the immortality of the soul.
And clearly this,
uh,
this view or this oppositional is one from,
call it between Athens.
It's very classical,
Athens and Jerusalem.
You may have heard of this.
The city of Athens by the way,
and that word itself means in mortality.
The mortality of Ah,
thanatos the mortality wisdom that wisdom survives,
but not that the,
the,
uh,
the people.
So there's a kind of a co called the kind of contrast between the two cities.
Very old,
very ancient,
a contrast.
And now,
and now we have in this part Epicurus and all his followers,
what do we call the epicureans and we just gloss the epicureans a little bit
further from then,
uh,
further than I did before.
There are two types in,
let me throw Griffith.
The epicureans.
They are true types of epicureans.
They,
whenever we think about the epicureans,
we think about those,
the vulgar epicureans,
those who think about and worship their stomach,
that pleasures of food and epicurean.
Uh,
in that sense,
I think that Dante is dramatized that kind of epicurean in Canto six when he
needs,
remember Chuck Kozo name means pig.
In fact,
we talk about the hogs of Epicurus,
you know,
the herd,
all the epicurious.
But then these,
the noble version of the Koreans can talk here in Canto 10.
Those who are interested in intellectual pleasures,
the pleasures of conversations,
the pressures of friendship,
the pleasures of meditation.
Uh,
and,
and there are those who do not,
who,
who removed themselves to the garden do not seem to really care much about what
happens around them because the,
in the belief that they should really take,
cultivate the soul and cultivate their own,
uh,
their own pursuits,
take care of their own pursuits.
That's what we are having here.
So these are the noble philosophical epicureans,
not the vulgar,
uh,
sold that believe in the,
in the supremacy of bodily pleasures.
Nonetheless,
pleasure is the aim of an epicurean ethics.
My pleasure.
Okay.
Um,
so,
uh,
this continues on this path.
Epicurus and all his followers who made the soul die with the body have the
burrito place.
How fitting,
how fitting is the,
the punishment for this crime?
This sin perfect.
Because these people never really believed in the immortality of the soul and
the air con them to be dead.
That's what they think.
And they dwell literally in sarcophagus.
Sarcophagi dry in,
in,
in tombs.
That's,
that's how they appear.
So there is another little detail I have given you some,
sometimes when we make wonder about the appropriateness of a sin of a punishment
for a particular sin,
but here we have no reason to,
to really be surprised at all,
but it's kind of,
uh,
of uh,
Destinee reserved for the Koreans.
But for their question to me,
that's your soon have satisfaction from within and for the desire to about which
there weren't silent and then they're interrupt a all of a sudden now,
Dante's once again involved.
And what's he a primary is not just no longer the question we mortality of
souls,
but how
the political aspect,
the political implications of this kind of belief or political implications.
I sort photo believe,
but believing in the mortality.
So how is this refracted onto the political scene as it were?
And again,
therefore this is almost a platonic conceit.
The relationship now between non on the body and cities.
We saw it in federal six,
but he sold and city it is this,
is this a solar city?
Uh,
what happens?
How,
how do we experience how livable,
which is officer,
I mean,
it is also a pun.
How livable is this kind of city,
uh,
when it happens and what is the,
what is the relationship?
What is the relationship between various figures?
But Dante's singles out are two people.
One,
a wealth in,
want to give a lien.
We are in the middle of the civil war or Florence.
Once again,
it's going to be Farinata,
a Gib Alene and a and the Cavalcanti the father,
the old man,
uh,
who is a wealth by the way,
that also related to each other because [inaudible] son [inaudible] best friend,
you remember he dedicates his Vita Nuova to him.
He calls him my first friend.
We though about canteen,
had married the daughter or Farinata.
They stand there in their tunes,
ignoring each other.
A niche,
ignoring the paints,
worries,
perplexities of the other.
It's a little picture of what it would call any city.
This is the city in the beyond where everybody's scrambling.
Nobody's paying attention to anybody else and everybody believes that one's own
passion.
Once one concern is really paramount and foremost,
there's nothing that can come equal,
can come near to it.
So it's all,
it's a candle that interestingly enough,
his mark by,
uh,
interruptions,
one is speaking,
the other one says,
forget it,
I got to talk now.
It's my turn.
And so it is,
it is the,
it is a little vignette of Florence in the year 1300 probably or later,
but 1300 is a good date for,
for us.
So he's interrupted.
Verger and Gunther interrupted by someone says,
or Tuscan,
who makes the way alive through the city of fire and speaks so modestly made,
please lead to stop.
At this point.
They tongue shows the,
uh,
native of Noble Fatherland to which high was perhaps I like that.
Perhaps too harsh.
Suddenly the sound issue from one of the chest and so on.
So they go on a turnaround.
What ails the says a virgin will see their Farinata who was reasonably wrecked
from the middle up the see his full height.
He appears from the navel up in the tomb.
And now a little historical detail.
Uh,
they used to be in Rome.
This church is still there,
but it was already there in the year 1300 when Dante went on an embassy to Rome,
the church,
so cold of the holy cross in Jerusalem,
which according to the legend,
it was built with material,
with stones from Jerusalem,
had been brought to Rome by Constantine's mother,
Helena in the,
uh,
in the basement of the church,
which would be open to only once a year.
Around the Easter season.
They would be in mosaic showing,
and you can cannot say we're the only on Good Friday that,
that,
uh,
the,
that basement would be open ended up mosaic.
It's no longer there.
So I cannot,
I'm not encouraging tourism.
It's just I'm giving you a little,
a little detail.
They used to be a mosaic of the,
uh,
rising Christ from shown from the navel up.
And it's clear here that the representation of funny Nada from the new show
himself from naval up is meant as a caricature of the belief in the
resurrection.
Yeah,
too.
This is really the story of a man who doesn't believe the resurrection.
And I can know graphically damn will go on in focusing insisting on this,
uh,
on the counter.
This man doesn't believe in the resurrection.
There is another possibility of looking at it.
So that is the description is deliberate.
It's clearly meant to evoke all of that.
So that is a great exchange between them who defeated home the tube,
the continuous battles between wealth and he believes,
and Dante claims that his own family managed to,
uh,
take a good revenge when the time came.
And clearly the implication is that more revenge,
ah,
since Dan has been,
uh,
we'll,
we'll uh,
would be necessary that interrupted by,
uh,
they're interrupted by this,
the site of a by the old man,
uh,
Cavalcanti Ah,
so you look at what the,
what the story of the canned toy is.
Funny.
Now the water is about his ancestors.
Cavalcanti worries about his son.
So these are the Koreans who have a sense of continuity,
some sense of dynastic continuity.
Oh,
within the imminence of personal concerns and family.
So they go,
they move beyond the,
the fragmentations of self from the others.
This im tool to have a kind of extended idea of themselves in spite of
themselves,
in spite of their beliefs.
This is what happens in extraordinary scene.
Then rose to sideline 55 and fallen beside him,
a shade showing as far as the chin.
I think he had lifted himself on his knees.
He looked around about me as if he had the desire to see whether someone was
with me.
But when his expectation was all quenched,
he said,
weeping.
If they'll goes through this blind prison by height of genius where this may
son.
And why is he not with the,
that offense clearly is to Dante's best friend to redow whose name also means
that he should be guiding him.
Maybe the old man,
the old father was hoping that the father,
the son,
according to his name,
could really be leading the younger poet.
Uh,
as he had led him in his early point,
the experiments in Florence and they,
he answers,
he's disappointed.
And then in them pants.
As I answered him,
I come,
not of myself,
he doesn't even mention him.
Meaning Virgil,
he the weights Yonder is leading me.
So this is um,
uh,
the Panam we though,
ah,
through here perhaps too.
That's,
I didn't clear the Texas he had.
My translation is to her and so does yours.
But many other translations probably would say something different.
Uh,
I will say two,
one to one.
You're,
we though held in this day and clear boost the herb would mean he's leading me.
Virgil leads me to Beatrice,
whom we though held in this and why would we though hell hold Beatrice in this
day.
And is this really the story of the Vita Nuova the,
the antagonism between we though and Beatrice,
there's nothing that really suggests all of that to one would be to God or to
some,
some aim that we though held in this day.
And we'll see what that means.
His words and the nature of his punishment had already told me his name.
Saw The pride,
does fully southernly erected,
cried how said style he held.
Oh,
that's
Dante uses the past credit.
He held the old man in first because of they use the past presidents that his
son is already dead and mistake,
but equivocation.
He's hailed,
leaves he and hold still strikes,
not the sweet light on his eyes.
When he perceived that I made some delay before replying,
he thought back again and we'll seen no more.
But Bob Farinata is unconcerned.
He goes on saying,
well,
yeah,
you drove us back,
but we drove you back.
Talk brings the subject to the political,
to the stick,
to the war between Wolfson gibberellins so that we really have to ask,
uh,
Dante goes on,
set please.
Before leaving,
reassure the old man that his son is still alive.
Because about a year of,
uh,
of,
the journey,
uh,
Dante,
we,
those supposed to be alive though he will die very quickly afterwards.
What is this story of political disarray of Florence and the story of the
encode,
the memory of,
uh,
dentist friend with whom he had just left the friendship was,
had,
had finished a friendship was over.
Um,
Dante,
for those of you who are interested in the biography of the poet,
that one of the early and toughest decisions you had to make was to banish,
we don't cover content from the city because he thought that we,
there was a cause of some unrest within the city.
Weedo went into exile and never made it back.
He died,
uh,
three months later,
in the swamps of neon of Liguria,
a little bit north of Tuscany.
Oh.
And so the Dante lives in many ways with the kind of guilt,
personal guilt,
I suppose he won't talk about it openly about,
uh,
the,
the what had been happening between them.
So what is,
how are we to understand this,
this scene?
Um,
let me just give you some,
some details about some other details about this scandal.
If you go through this blind prison by height of genius,
a little bit of irony there.
Cavalcanti clearly there's not understand.
No.
Can he understand that Dante's journey,
the beyond is not due to high to genius,
but these are the philosophers and he has a kind of philosophical idea about how
certain experiences are going to be possible.
W Y why is not my son with you?
Uh,
I said I come not of myself.
He that to one whom your widow held in this day in,
uh,
well,
um,
what is,
what has happened here?
Who is widowed really we do is what we call in a verus did you ever hear the
term [inaudible]?
Probably not.
Other roles.
Dante actually mentions him in limbo,
was an Arab philosopher and the famous commentator of toto and the all the
techs,
he commented the just as now in the Middle Ages,
they would be reading the great classics or philosophy,
especially at very,
very difficult texts such as the on the soul of,
at his photo with it following the commentators have a,
rose was known as the,
the great commentator.
He was the great commentator,
uh,
of artists photos on this hole.
And he argues that Aristo too does not believe in the immortality of the soul.
That's the argument that he's going to be challenged by Aquinas and by many
others.
But that's the primary.
We look over.
Country follows other rowers understanding about the soul.
So that the one who is here,
uh,
a heretic,
so to speak,
it's not just the old men but also Rido governor can't himself.
Let me say at this point before I go any further telling you more about the,
the um,
waste an awareness that,
what does it mean to be an various,
I did have to raise that point with you.
What does Harrison mean?
Cause I did indicate that in antiquity it was never really thought of as a sin
because it's a question of,
of,
of mind.
The word comes from the Greek.
I raises meaning to choose one who is,
um,
he's a heretic is someone who makes it into a particular intellectual choice.
And to be,
uh,
to be viewed as a sinner,
you have to also indicate some kind of an element of pride behind,
uh,
a particular belief.
And so we though is held responsible for spreading,
disseminating this idea of a verus Maurice than a virus.
Well,
one of the ideas that are that that other rose says is that we in the commentary
on the soul,
that we human beings,
we human beings are not even capable,
intrinsically capable of thinking
that we are made.
Remember the famous structure,
the diagram about the soul,
that we are our concupiscence entities and sensitive entities.
Well also rational entities,
but the rationality of curse to us intermittently thoughts.
We even say that in English a thought came to me that reminds me the best way of
understanding our various,
we don't think all the time occasionally thought comes to us and there's no way
that really,
and when we think we are really in existence a sort of break this continuity
from the world of feeling.
So there's a fairly tragic understanding making human beings the object of
thoughts,
not subjects of thoughts.
We are not agents capable of producing thoughts,
thoughts come to us.
And uh,
also tragic because it in it,
it sort of presents a,
Eh,
a break between the sensitive part of our experiences and the rational parts of
experiences.
We live like animals most,
most,
more often than not,
we eat,
we drink,
we sleep and so on.
Then occasionally we managed to disengage ourselves from all of this and capable
of contemplative thought.
At that point we no longer really live.
We are.
We are just,
we are.
We are abstracted from ourselves.
We are removed from ourselves.
Not only we don't believe in these ideas,
these ideas shape.
One of the most beautiful poems are written at the time of Dante by we Dakar
can't himself and the poem is called,
a lady asks me,
I want to tell you what the poem is about.
It's a point where he,
there's a fiction are the poet.
We though cover can't imagines that a woman may have been the case,
asks him to define love as you pour it are always talking about love and I don't
understand what you mean by love and nor do I understand what,
what are the effects of love?
And he writes,
his honor,
this is a long song saying that love.
A lady asked me to talk about the nature of love,
the function of love and the effects of love.
And it goes on almost scholastically,
taking one case after the other.
He begins by saying in the exposition that love is a passion that comes from
Mars,
not from Venus.
There is to say the nature of love is always to be,
uh,
one of conflict and one of war and chaos,
not one of an ordered the benevolent Vinas.
He goes on to saying that it's a,
uh,
it induces death and it's characterized by deliriums of the mind is a very
clearly grim idea of love.
What Dante's do in this candle 10 is connecting with ideas of love and the
politics of civil war.
He finds that there is a strictness necessarily connection and it struck the end
necessarily core relation between the thinking about love of Wheelock,
of our can't take home.
Downto pauses as you'll know from the Vita Nuova.
But he believes that Beatrice can indeed be someone who can lead them to God and
to the knowledge of God in the persuasion that it is not by truth,
that you come to the knowledge of God.
If you cannot come to the knowledge of God by truth,
then how do you come to the knowledge of God?
By love,
by thinking about laugh.
That's the way of the,
of the,
the ascent.
And on the other hand,
Dante,
we'll have this idea that it,
uh,
that the political,
the order of civil,
that the bizarre,
the civil disorder,
the civil war is nothing else than the phenomenon of a theory put forth by the
Verus a by Guido coupled county.
So this is,
this is really what I think,
that double focus of this scandal love in politics and the connection between
them.
A connection with which,
by the way,
uh,
the Averroes,
Sandia Pq and from Dante links with the epicureans are denied,
but he's making this connection imaginatively connection denied by the
philosophers themselves with Ken to 11.
And I,
Dan too.
We'll go on.
We'll have a few minutes and I can talk about this.
Dante,
as I said,
explains the,
uh,
the older of,
so the,
on the face of it,
the juxtaposition is clear to the disorder of the city.
We are not going to have a reflection,
irrational reflection on,
uh,
the,
the older that sustains the,
the city of hair if there is any disordered place.
It this as if there is a large,
even to the,
these older of a,
of evil.
And the idea is that they are,
there's a tripartite division to this to hell.
The plan of her,
uh,
all the sins are divided into three parts since of incontinence that we saw from
Canto.
Uh,
three,
uh,
four,
five actually two Canto,
uh,
nine,
the middle area,
which is called the area of violence and which,
and then the third area,
the scene since of fraud and Dante calls fraud.
They seem peculiar to human beings because it's not just a scene of the will,
but there is also the premeditation of the mind,
the complexity of the mind,
the since of fraud fraud,
which has also since of treasury.
Uh,
Dante sees the conjunction of will and at the same time at the order of reason
in the performance of,
uh,
of that,
of that evil and they can talk,
comes to Eh,
with uh,
ends with a question to say is that this is all from the ethics of at the stall
and then the Dante wonders look,
hearsay you are lines 90,
oh son that he list all troubled side.
So does that satisfy me with the resolving of my doubts that it is not as
grateful to me to question than to know,
turn back again a little.
I said to the point,
you know me to explaining everything.
Actually he didn't explain everything.
He never explained heresy,
which we took some time to talk about and he never really explains.
Dan tells you never really say anything about usury.
Uh,
the,
the usually offense is the divine goodness,
a loose that not why is usually what is usually exactly.
And the question is why does them to ask this question of usury?
How does he answered it?
Cause that we can understand the why he asks about it.
How does he answer?
What usually is a,
let me just read this passage lines 98 and foreign philosophy for one one the
stands he said to me,
no,
it's not in one place only how nature takes a course from divine mind and it's
art if they're not well by physics and other text of Aristotle.
The ethics has mentioned for us now the physics that will find not many pages on
that you art as far as it can follows nature is the pupil,
the master so that your art is to God as it were and grandchild by this too.
If you recall to mind genesis near the beginning,
the biblical book of Genesis,
it behooves mankind to gain the level of hood ended advancement and because the
usual takes another way.
He despises nature both in herself and in her follower setting his hope
elsewhere but now follow me for I would go,
the fishes are quivering on the horizon and all the way in lies over cowers and
farther on that is the descent of the,
to explain the scene of usually Dante puts forth it,
theory of art.
That's what's happening as if you usually wear a violation of art.
How does he understand that art?
What is art?
The he understands artists' work.
That's the best way to explain it,
right?
Talking about the beginning of Genesis,
when human being,
when Adam was thrown out of the garden of Eden and was told that in order to
recover,
retrieve the garden,
he had to call but go to work.
That work becomes anesthetic,
not a punishment.
He had tests and see work as a punishment but in ascetic exercise whereby one
can regain or transform the wilderness into paradise.
That's really the idea.
But I think that is more that is happening here in this connection.
But this is the general thrust of the camp.
What is art in the Middle Ages?
You may want to know because first of all,
uh,
I did say that there is a general coherence.
You remember those were the main initial words when I started today.
Today's class from Ken [inaudible] to Ken to 11 art is understood by the
scholastics as a virtue of the practical intellect in the older of making and
virtue of the practical intellect.
And you may under what is this practical intellect,
how many intellects that we have.
While there's a practice,
there's a speculative intellect when Dante talks about the immortality of the
soul and those who do not believe in the mortality of this.
So that's a question of the speculative intellect.
If I went home thinking about God,
suppose that I had this
weakness of mine to think about justice for instance,
of an abstract idea of justice,
you know,
particular cases of justice and then I'm involved in an exercise of the
speculative intellect.
He ends the Canto with the practical intellect and emphasis on the practical
interest.
It's their mind that worries about doing or making and they are not too.
They're not the same thing.
What is the difference to say that there is a practical intellect in the order
of doing would be to worried about when you talk about prudence is a virtue of
doing was it's not,
it's not the artisans work to say that,
that it's a virtual,
the practical intellect in the order of making it means that the work of art is
a think that one elaborates.
It's there.
From this point of view,
the issue is never really one of our visit.
Tell the truth about whatever.
It has its own thinkness it's a thing,
the work of artists,
something made and therefore has made it has its own reality.
It its own laws,
its own rigor.
That's one thing.
So it's work.
But look at all the images that Dante's using to uh,
reflect on this problem.
Philosophy for one,
one the stands,
he said to me notes not in one place only how nature takes a course from the
divine mind and it's hot and the know,
well they physics,
which is um,
it's a theory of,
of nature.
Really.
It's a theory of motion.
It's a theory of how things grow.
Uh,
how things are,
are born,
grow and parish,
right.
Um,
that we'll find not many pages are on that.
Your art is fun as it can.
Photos.
Nature is the pupil,
the master,
so that your artists to gods as it were a grandchild.
I just want to talk about this metaphors here to make you understand what Dante,
Dante understands art on the face of it.
He saying that art must be an invitation of nature,
right?
You had follow nature.
So this does Dante.
Then I have a mimetic idea of art.
Not at all.
Because look at the metaphors he's using.
Um,
two metaphors.
You're as far as it can photos.
Nature is the pupil,
the pastor,
so that your art is to God as it were a grandchild.
Because art follows nature.
Nature is the child of God.
So art is a grandchild,
but it's an image of fecundity and fertility.
You can understand why dental posters,
art finally to usury usually is viewed as the activity that is sterile and
activity that produces what's symbolic money out of money,
money.
So it's a symbolic kind of operation as opposed to it.
Dante opposes with Dante casts the virtue of art as work,
but one of production,
one of generation that the grandchild of God,
art is the grandchild of that.
And then there is this other metaphor is the pupil follows the master,
which is not a gratuitous metaphor because of their own,
the,
within the context here,
Dante is,
has virtual is teaching him.
So there's also almost a kind of flattery if you wish.
One little detail is flattering.
The,
the,
uh,
the relationship.
We are,
acknowledges his discipleship to Virgil,
which he does all the time,
but it implies the educational aspect of art in the most of the technological
sense of the term art educator in the sense that he leads us out of a particular
state of what a cold call it barbarity ignorance,
a darkness,
et Cetera.
So he has an educational and no mimetic uh,
role because art imitates the productive rhythms of the natural world.
Dante views an art that is open to beginnings to life.
This is the meaning of Genesis,
the idea of genesis and art that all is that is original but not in a romantic
sense of originality.
But I not,
that leads us back to the thought of origins,
the thought of how things come into being.
Because only then do we understand how or what the ends are to understand the
ends.
We got to know something about the beginnings,
about the seeds that make us,
uh,
forever.
It is that we think we are.
So,
uh,
we have gone then from Kenton nine to come to 11 from concerns about the pride
of the mind.
Uh,
the,
uh,
which we could even call it would even call the wound the wound of the intellect
and the weakness of the will tool.
Uh,
the view that really is no distinction between an epicurean thinking about one's
health in the state and a distinct from some kind of theorizing them to see this
connection between them to finally,
uh,
an idea of art.
I think that this idea of art is also for Dante remedial for the evils,
uh,
that to which we are prone,
Dante,
things that should we apply to ourselves.
The same kind of care of rigor with which an artist produces the work of art.
Then what do we call the cultivation of this whole main deed?
Uh,
begin to take place.
Okay.
So art,
the tension,
Dante's attention to art is part of this ascetic exercise.
We finish here.
It was,
that will have given us a few minutes as I touched on a number of issues and I'm
anxious to hear your perplexities,
uh,
questions,
comments,
suggestions,
whatever.
Yes.
It makes it so clear that they send me,
I really,
you have
yes.
Because of analytes in,
well,
it's not just because they're thinking something.
The question is with the head ethics that we are not really dealing only with
the question of thought or it's a freedom of thought,
but uh,
it's not,
uh,
deals with the fact that so the heretics are engaged in enact of Intel acts of
intellect which are supported,
are shaped by also acts of the will.
That's that it was exactly what I maintained.
That makes sense.
But then it,
does he ever really try and explain to them,
I mean,
everyone wonders about the virtuous pagans and why they're there and it seems
that there's
really no failure
for the before the,
for Dante you mean?
Ah,
the question is about the Pagans are the standard thing that there is,
are not just the failure.
If I understood the question of the failure of the intellect,
but also the failure of the wheel.
Yes.
I think that this is a,
this is the case.
Uh,
we shall see a number of pagans were probably,
we can highlight,
we can,
we can see highlighted some of this,
uh,
this concerns that he has,
concerns.
You will read the Ulysses who is represented as engaged in a flight of the minds
that wings of the intellect,
you know,
they are wings of desire,
platonic wings of desire,
and then Francesca can't,
or five,
you know,
you remember she says like a dove,
tell her,
uh,
cold by desire,
the open wings,
clearly the wings on his idea.
And then in the case of your list is you're going to have the,
the,
the wings of the,
of the,
of the intellect,
uh,
the mind that tries to reach or the flight or the mind.
Um,
but he,
he tool he tool appears as,
as,
as a rhetorician this to say,
it would seem that we like to believe that there is a distinction between the
say a metaphysical since the devil,
but physics as a,
uh,
a kind of metaphysical intellectual flight and not is always saying,
look,
uh,
is it taking to all his probe the presence of passions,
the rhetorical aspect of,
uh,
the claims to reach the truth or the plain of truth?
Oh,
yes.
Am I answering your question though?
I mean,
it's also just,
you know,
which is why they say we're still in house.
Okay.
Okay,
good.
Uh,
then,
uh,
I have been missing the mark in answering,
and the question really is how are they pagans in hell?
Because Christ had not yet calm.
And in what way did they violate
the federal return?
Uh,
no,
the answer is no.
No.
Uh,
and they may give you a general idea why it's no,
and then their particular idea,
first of all,
generally is if,
if Dante word to drudge and he does judge the world,
the culture of,
uh,
let's say Greek,
the classical world,
he puts it most of it in limbo.
That's a judgment.
Then you know,
you're up,
you're really marginal.
You're eliminated to my story.
That's,
that's what he's saying.
Ah,
they'll in paradise,
who will go out of the way to reclaim Plato,
Waterstone and all the possibilities for periods.
If he were to do that from a perspective which is outside,
I don't,
he really would be a boring port in my view.
You know,
I,
you don't believe in the mortality of the soul as his fever saying copiers.
I do.
Uh,
you're a fool and therefore I'm saved and I put you in hell.
That's,
that's,
that's really not worthy of,
of,
of of a great mind because one can imagine a peculiar sang by you or the full,
and you think you are saved.
I know what I have been known.
So you can,
you can take,
says [inaudible] never does that.
He does do is take the perspective of the sinners themselves,
let them talk and gives them a rope with which they hang themselves.
That's really what's happening.
That's the best way to present this argument.
Uh,
so he's not judging the Pagans.
And I'm coming straight to your question.
He's not judging the Pagans from a Christian standpoint alone.
That is outside of it for a number of reasons,
because he believes actually that whatever,
ah,
the,
the Pagans,
Geraldo Abrasions of the Christian,
the view of the Christian vision,
there are no just other to be rejected on the contrary.
And then in particular,
I can say that they will go on placing some pagans say among the saved he even
places one figure,
uh,
the,
the Socorro refills who was only mentioned once.
And we know nothing about him.
I Roman who just,
who's a sailor in,
in with an ies and only because virtual refers to him as Eustace Rafales use to
survive that just refuse,
which is to me a way which Dante says,
not just the kings,
but then very simple,
humble,
uh,
um,
worker can also be safe trade or the emperor Trajan and so on.
So there are a number of other cases in the case of virtual,
I'm not going to go there because I'm going to be on TV for the next six months.
I don't know,
uh,
how many the,
because reams of books have been written by people who wish to see him saved.
I mean,
it's such,
such a good guy throughout in fair.
No.
And,
and pull gatory on the,
and the people who go on arguing that he,
he might,
uh,
he,
he may be saying,
one thing we know is that he comes as far as the garden of Eden and justice
about Beatrice is going to arrive.
The pilgrim,
the lover.
Now,
Dante trembles at the idea that he or she is the destination of his journey and
he needs the help of,
of,
of Virgil.
He turns around and his eyes will never see him again.
He had vanished.
So we know that there is a kind of,
uh,
that seems to be the limitation,
how far he can go.
But to say this really to say very little or because within Dante's Cosmo,
Dante,
Dante is an idea of the curvature of space.
Okay?
The sphere
into a redemption means that all things will go back to the beginning.
That's what happens.
So only from that point of view,
we don't have a lot of thematic or reflections about this aspect.
Who is going to be saved at the end of that?
Who knows?
The whole question is the unfathomable quality of God's justice.
Dante wonders though,
uh,
you know,
we're talking about Christ and Christ and what about the,
in those living in the hint on the banks of the Hindus,
they never heard the name of Christ and they're going to be saved and they are
just,
can they be condemned?
These are questions that he will not answer.
He raises this question is in paradise,
so you're a little bit impatient I say,
but I think that from the point of view of eschatology are he must have an idea
of otherwise redemption has failed.
If,
if some people are damned,
then there is no redemption.
You see what I'm saying?
Uh,
in the measuring which evil,
if you,
if you get into this metaphysical a framework,
uh,
if they are going to be residues of,
of,
of sin,
then that is also rescue of injustice.
I don't know that I answered your question.
I think I did,
but,
oh
yes.
I understand the idea of him just as an allegory for mediation poetry.
But is it also a connection between the figure of the woman and the act of
Petrick vacation taking about the donut?
Petra,
I'm wondering if don is also saying something about the danger of this love,
right.
The dangers of misplaced love.
Thank you.
The question is,
uh,
about the,
the stove,
the Medusa,
uh,
and the,
the part about the mediation of poetry to conquer Medusa is clear.
But,
uh,
the question,
the question also wonders whether this has to do with,
first of all the fact that the Medusa's have woman and uh,
and also the pit that pit suffocation is the petrol vacation of misplaced love.
Is that an accurate,
the paraphrase.
Okay.
And the answer is,
that's a great question.
I sense there are your awareness of the fraud,
the reading of the myth of the Medusa,
uh,
s castration,
s s s a d,
the kind of literalization of the,
the threat at least not cost to you,
but the threat of castration on the mail from the point of view.
Or maybe it was,
uh,
um,
okay.
I will take the second part of your,
your remark to explain also the first part.
I think that this is a question of a misdirected love,
but what Nan has seen,
um,
I would urge you to go and read the poems about this.
Uh,
a lady pay tra the Lady of stone,
uh,
because there are poems were non politically engages in fantasies of violence
against,
against her.
Oh,
you fuck with get my hands on her.
That with a passion I requited makes him,
um,
well it's almost sort of sadistic,
sadistic coloring,
uh,
about about it.
So I think it's clearly misdirected love.
What he understands though is the kind of death that that sort of desperate love
has brought to him.
You can call that,
you can view that death is the fear of castration.
I think it's an extreme version of that.
So I would agree.
I would agree with,
with what I hear is behind you.
Okay.
Question.
Yes.
Why does he draw us into that allegory?
I,
uh,
you mean if it's a,
the question is why does he draw us into the link or if it's about petrified
love.
Ah,
right.
This is the question and that presume I don't want to explain your question.
I have to answer your question,
but I presume that your question stems from your,
your kind of concern you have.
If it's such a private story,
why us?
In what way are we involved in that?
This is his story,
right?
Uh,
and the answer that I could give is yes,
this is,
it can be seen as Dante's own confession.
And the confession.
And that's why I read the passage from Augustan Augustan.
So on confessions,
a confession that can also be exemplary to us.
And because he thinks,
I think that there are no experiences,
challenges just reuse,
bubbly,
private,
and therefore I'm sharable.
Uh,
it's part of the concern of this writing or this writer that anything that will
happen to him.
We,
we,
I have to say this,
we are going to find moments when he tells us his night dreams.
Um,
pretty heavy night dreams with treated with an extraordinary,
I think care.
Um,
but we're going to have this,
we're going to enter into his psyche why,
of way of entering the psyche because he has to,
to understand not only how shareable are his,
uh,
his,
his experiences,
but also what is the root of,
um,
the wig.
We make decisions.
Um,
dual can we really be ever all the time vigilant.
This isn't the case of the dream and my responsible.
If I,
if I perceive the world in a certain way and my responsible,
if dreams come to me in a certain way,
then am I accountable for this kind of dreams.
So the concern is always that of trying to the limit an area where there is some
common ground between his experiences and hours.
And that's the transactional value.
The Corey,
okay.
Yes.
I don't know if it's significant,
but Dante turns to the right.
Yes.
Did you find that significant?
Just going back to
oh,
of course.
Okay.
This is fantastic.
This,
uh,
the question is,
I have been talking about the fact that in uh,
in in fair,
no,
Dante goes,
uh,
to the left seems to,
which I also said though that that is really very difficult to visualize.
So we say counter clockwise or clockwise that he's,
the seventh is a clockwise in,
in fandom.
And yet I'm so grateful to you for noticing this.
Uh,
he had a new fare,
no,
nine.
Dante actually goes out of the way to say that he turned to the right and the
the,
I don't have a position of my own on this,
but they'll also be,
well,
this is 24 size.
That heresy is primarily the disease of the intellect.
You know,
you remember that I,
I specify that that is the will and intellect and they will,
is always the left.
And the intellect is the right.
I think that Dante is,
uh,
this is the point where Dante is,
sleeping.
It happened to Houma occasionally to fall asleep.
And this is that the only time that you have caught him,
those enough.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
We'll see you next time.